[Música]
con nuestra primera invitada del día
vamos a hablar del desbloqueo de los
puertos ucranianos donde hoy salió el
primer barco cargado con al menos 26.000
toneladas de cereales esto gracias a un
acuerdo firmado entre kiev y moscú con
la intermediación de turquía y la onu
además la reanudación de las
exportaciones desde ucrania que van a
aliviar y eso espera por supuesto toda
la comunidad internacional la crisis
alimentaria económica mundial agudizadas
por esta guerra además que afectan a
sobre todo al continente asiático y al
africano algunos países de esos
continentes analizamos entonces las
implicaciones comprende stephanie ya
analista internacional brenda muy buen
día gracias por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24 y también
nos acompaña en nuestro estudio en el
hablando y ya nuestra periodista
económica de nuestras mañanas aquí en
directo américa muy buenos dias brenda
buenos días venga pues primero iniciemos
con qué representa esto para el mundo
sabiendo que ucrania y rusia son
despensas mundiales de alimentos
así es ucrania y rusia son llamados el
granero del mundo hasta antes del inicio
de la guerra eran responsables por la
exportación del 30% del trigo que se
exportaba a nivel global y desde el
inicio de la guerra que entre 80 y 90
grandes buques están varados en los
puertos ucranianos sin poder salir a
estos puertos han estado dominados
incluso muchas de estas minas fueron
colocadas por el gobierno ucraniano para
evitar una invasión por parte de rusia a
través de ellos y ahora a través de este
acuerdo que se logró hace unos diez días
bajo la égida de naciones unidas y el
gobierno de turquía en donde tanto el
gobierno de rusia como el de ucrania
firmaron documentos idénticos pero por
separado porque ucrania se negó a firmar
en el mismo documento que el país que
está invadiendo lo y sin embargo se
llega hoy por primera vez a la
liberación de este primer back
es complicado porque por un lado hay que
retirar las minas el gobierno ucraniano
el ejército ucraniano quiere asegurarse
que esto no permita abrir rutas de
entrada a navíos rusos que pudieran
utilizar esta vía para invadir los
puertos ucranianos y por otro lado
asegurarse que estos barcos pues
transitan bajo condiciones de seguridad
hasta su destino final y que puedan
entrar otros barcos para también a su
vez recargarse de señales es todo un
proceso complejo en el cual están
puestos los ojos del mundo por la
importancia que tiene esto para
disminuir la crisis de alimentos y
aliviar digamos esta presión que hay
sobre la seguridad alimentaria a nivel
global brenda ahora también este acuerdo
digamos se tardó un poco debido a las
garantías que esperaba ucrania de rusia
incluso se suponía que este viernes que
pasó zarpaba el primer barco recordemos
que este acuerdo también comenzó con
tropiezos porque rusia pues no digamos
guardo su palabra de no atacar a ucrania
y atacó el puerto de odessa entonces con
todo este contexto que tenemos qué
garantías hay de que realmente ya rusia
si respete a partir de hoy cuando ya
zarpó el primer barco recordamos también
que estos barcos están pues manejados o
por civiles que no tienen absolutamente
nada que ver con esta con esta guerra
digamos que no hay ningún tipo de
militares de ningún bando ni el otro
entonces cuáles son realmente esas
garantías para que rusia no ataque o
anuncie que ya no va a respetar este
pacto de digamos no atacar para
resguardar la seguridad de estas
personas en los buques
pues es una pregunta interesante porque
más allá de la firma del documento pues
es difícil saber si rusia cumplirá o no
su palabra de entrada como bien señalaba
al día siguiente de la firma del acuerdo
cuando como se dice todavía estaba
fresca la tinta hay un ataque por parte
del ejército ucraniano al puerto de
odessa el principal puerto ucraniano
dentro del mar negro y fundamental
digamos para la exportación de cereales
esto generó mucha duda si realmente se
iba a poder llevar a cabo no la
exportación de los cereales y no ha sido
el único evento el día de ayer
justamente un día antes de la liberación
de este primer barco en los ataques séa
mykolaiv perdió la vida el principal
empresario de logística de cereales de
ucrania uno de los hombres más ricos del
país uno de los empresarios más
conocidos pero sobre todo un empresario
serial ero que murió en su casa junto
con su mujer en un ataque que
directamente tuvo como objetivo su
residencia entonces este tipo de
elementos de la mano de una guerra e
intensidad que continúa pues generan
enormes dudas sobre cuánto más podrá
exportarse en un contexto pues desde
luego de guerra porque más allá de estos
acuerdos que puedan tomarse pues bajo la
égida de organismos internacionales lo
cierto es la guerra de alta intensidad
continua que la inversión a ucrania
continua y los bombardeos incluso este
fin de semana en regiones más allá de la
línea de batalla pues generan dudas
porque pareciera que rusia continúa con
esta estrategia del error de querer
aterrorizar a la ciudad ucra a la
sociedad ucraniana para que ésta digamos
ponga presión sobre sus autoridades para
que estas capítulo brenda qué va a pasar
en términos de precios y también de
disponibilidad de granos en el mundo
quienes han sido por ejemplo estos
países que han suplido esa falta de maíz
o de trigo desde desde ucrania y qué va
a pasar entonces ahora ya hoy los
precios del maíz y del trigo están
bajando cerca del 2 por ciento pero que
podemos esperar en el mediano plazo en
ese sentido
los los mercados están reaccionando a
las decisiones que se tomen hace 10 días
con el acuerdo inicial una baja
importante en el precio sobre todo del
trigo y de los futuros del trigo en
mercados como el de chicago y el día de
hoy nuevamente con este primer buque que
zarpa vuelve a ver una baja de los
precios de cereales y en los futuros de
estos de todas maneras el mercado está
muy nervioso digamos y está muy atento a
los desarrollos esta disminución del
precio puede cambiar en el momento en el
que se vea interrumpida la evacuación de
estos barcos cerealeros el que además no
solamente llevan cereales sino incluso
decir que llevan fertilizantes también y
aceite de girasol productos estos
también de exportación ucraniana y
fundamentales para la economía global y
me parece que estaremos viendo un
mercado muy atento a los sucesos de la
región particularmente en el mar negro
en los próximos días ahora vemos eso ya
todo la palabra vemos eso digamos con
estas a toneladas represadas en estos
puertos ucranianos pero digamos que pasa
actualmente con esta producción de
cereales y granos en ucrania cómo hacer
para mantener digamos esta producción y
seguir sufriendo al mundo con los granos
y no sería sino simplemente sacar lo que
está represado
pues los reportes indican que como parte
digamos de esta invasión rusa también el
ejército ha colocado minas en zonas
agrícolas de alguna manera rusia tiene
claro que los puertos de ucrania son
fundamentales para su economía pero que
es un sector agrícola lo es también y
está buscando en maneras de presionarlo
para tener un mayor control desde luego
de la economía de ucrania y a partir de
medio de la toma de decisiones del
gobierno ucraniano es difícil saber a
qué grado ha sido afectado hay análisis
indican si el que ha disminuido la
producción hasta en un 50 por ciento y
eso se verá hasta el siglo siguiente y
aunado a los crecientes efectos del
cambio climático que en países como la
india han hecho una disminución de la
producción y también ha que ante la
falta de los productos de ucrania en el
mundo hay países como indonesia claro
que ha decidido por ejemplo no exportar
parte de su aceite de caña o debido a
que
el aceite de girasol ucraniano ha salido
del mercado y esto estas decisiones de
terceros países' alentadas por lo que
sucede en ucrania pues también afectan
los precios a nivel global